[Musique]
alors
vous avez vu lola jean-marie vous ne
reconnaissez retrouvez nous sur frey sur
ces huit heures
[Musique]
la légende voilà lé vieux bureau voilà
j'ai un peu peur bien d'avoir mal à
l'âme on peut faire mieux sur mon île où
ça va les gars là tout allait bien donc
on va voir ça va bien se passer
on est très content très content qu un
sens bien vitesse un peu beaucoup pas
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup et
je trouve les missions particulièrement
amusant et poser question
[Musique]
c'est très puissant bien au jeu alors
moi je suis sûr qu'il ya un défaut sur
le sur la piste mais bon non non la
folie très bon pied voilà je sais qu'une
étoile et constance de son frère et
jolies choses avec l'extérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah oui justement qu'est jean carrazé
parti socialiste sa berline d'éducation
middle voilà et à berlin c'est par
l'abbé sanary là mes productions marc
dorcel doit passer cassis pour sa part
parlé je veux savoir pourquoi
[Musique]